you know how you just have to look at
yourself from me like what up this is
good enough hey guys it is Thursday
you're on its grace tipsy Thursday where
I give you tips and tricks etcetera and
how to do something by the time you are
watching this video I will either be in
or on my way to London for some no
filter comedy shows with Hannah and
mamrie so I thought that today would be
really appropriate to give you my I
guess top 10 travel tips for traveling
smart or than the below average person
we got there always make sure you have
socks and underwear you wouldn't go to
Antarctica and not bring it coat so
bring the coach Frayer chosen those I
don't know how many times I've had to
settle for wearing dirty socks or dirty
underwear or no socks and go underwear
just hoping that I get through security
without a TSA pat down just bring more
clean socks and more clean underwear
than you think you need it doesn't take
a blunt room in your bag when you're
wearing dirty socks or dirty underwear
it just affects you on a personal level
and I feel like I act out towards other
people because silently in the back of
my brain I know I've subjected myself to
dirty underwear
so I'm sorry society for my mistakes
before you leave a hotel give yourself
an extra five minutes to do one or two
more laps through every single area of
that room to make sure you have
everything you need I don't know you
maybe you got wasted last night and
decided that your license would be
safest in the top part of the toilet it
happens to the best of us to be I would
say would be to create a checklist in
your mind of the most important things
that you need anything that you really
that's going to be the biggest
pain-in-the-ass to replace credit cards
ideas chargers the Chargers football
team etc always assume that a plane
doesn't have Wi-Fi I know I sound like a
jaded spoiled millennial piece of [ __ ]
assume that you are going to have to
entertain yourself with things that are
outside of an onboard entertainment
system and/or the internet bring books
bring magazines bring audio books I've
told you guys before about this and I'm
going to tell you again and everyone on
YouTube it tells you about this
audible.com is a downloadable service /
books they have over 150,000 books I own
two books maybe but you basically go on
the website and download a book and then
store it on your listening device and
then listen to it when you're traveling
and it's great I've already downloaded
Paper Towns by John Green I read The
Fault in Our Stars and now the movies
coming out Paper Towns got a movie deal
with Fox and I want to listen to this
book before I see the movie because when
I read The Fault in Our Stars at all so
I read it on a plane and it gave me a
panic attack on the plane because it was
so beautiful so here's hoping also
audible has given me my very own unique
URL audible.com slash appraise so that
you guys if you want to can go on there
and download up your first download for
free no dinero donde esta el pesos know
where you don't need it because you can
just go to audible.com slash great
always travel with some sort of
cleansing wipes they can be used for a
variety of things on your person
and or etc white father right
Oh God bring some sort of stomach
medication I know you have a rock-solid
stomach your digestive system is great
[ __ ] you
you never know when that mount sue vyas
is gonna be like but screw you us we're
gonna tamper with the security system
you have going on down there
tsa more like that's gas just bring
something make friends with the flight
attendants I've only recently learned
this that if you make friends with
flight attendants sometimes they give
you free booze not all the time not all
the time it just depends on the person
they have the access to the two things
that you really want on a plane
beverages and food they're really
powerful gatekeepers dry shampoo dry
shampoo dry shampoo I can't say this
enough a lot of times when I travel and
I get off a plane there might be
something I have to go to right away and
I don't have enough time to get my full
person together take a shower drying
hair takes a long time
whatever so I love dry shampoo also just
in life in general
Wendy Diaz who is a hair stylist that
did my hair for a couple shoots that I
had recently just gave me this dry
shampoo called pure ology fresh approach
and it's great much la don't you do this
look how great that looks I'm pretty
sure that Wendy gave meteorology cause
we were talking about travel and dry
shampoo and told me that pure ology
makes a travel-size formula that you can
bring with you Thank You Wendy JDS on
instagram always bring headphones or get
headphones when you get onto your
transportation device even if you are
not going to listen to anything
audible they allow you to create a box
of isolation for your
because if you do this but these are
plugged into anything but if you just
hide the plug in a place where the
person next you can't really tell it's
plugged into anything who's gonna want
to disturb this would you disturb that
if you said yes you if you said no
you've been raised by really good people
try to keep all your important documents
in one place I am notorious for bringing
a few purses or bags with me when I
travel so I can have options cuz I'm a
girl and usually what happens is that I
take my IDs and credit cards out of my
wallet and I put them into a smaller
purse and then somehow they get jumbled
around and I end up losing one of them
so just try to keep them all in one
place and my last tip is have a great
time boost do you like traveling do you
like traveling
mmm-hmm that was just sew that onto a
pillow